the movie begins with a narration from
an old book recounting a time where
Earth was dominated by menacing
creatures such as werewolves vampires
demons and goblins goblins as the
centuries passed by these fearsome
creatures decided to change their way of
life and became peaceloving beings some
of them started Living with humans
undetected while the others fled to
various Secret locations across the
world the scene then cuts to the present
time and we are introduced to a young
vampire Vlad and his father Barnabas who
are driving towards a magical town
called CRS Feldon it appears that the
boy's father wants him to start his
first year of school at a renowned Magic
School unfortunately along the way their
navigation system stops working and
they're lost in a deep forest as they
stop by a stone bridge they are suddenly
approached by a creepy old man Quasimodo
who asks for their documents turns out
that this old man has been serving as
the guard of the bridge for over a
millennium he then opens a giant book
and reads A prophec phy about Vlad whom
he claims as part of an ancient curse
after verifying their documents
Quasimoto helps them with their way to
CRS Feldon the father and son finally
enter the magical town that seems to be
of the Medieval Era it's a small and
unique town in the middle of nowhere
while driving around the streets a
cyclist suddenly comes in their way
causing Barnabas to hit the brakes in an
emergency the duo steps out to check the
man's well-being and finds that one of
the bicycle's wheels has mysteriously
shrunk just then a police officer shows
up at the scene to investigate the
incident Vlad is seen wearing a Dark
Crystal around his neck which seems to
be carrying out magic tricks on its own
such as changing the officer's hat this
explains how the bicycle's wheel
suddenly got smaller however Vlad is
completely unaware that his crystal is
doing all of this however he has long
suspected that it did something similar
to his pee after sorting out the
incident Vlad and his father arrive at
their new home which is right above an
antique shop sh Vlad doesn't like the
house as it's very old and feels that
it's ready to crumble moreover he is a
bit nervous about his new school so
Barnabas Comforts him saying that
there's nothing to worry about by the
time it gets dark Barnabas finishes
unpacking and arranging their place
before putting his son to bed a short
while later a strange man in a cloak
appears in their house startling
Barnabas for a moment this man
introduces himself as a tax official and
hands him a list of bills he must pay
while he's in the town not even God
goblins can get out of paying taxes the
following morning Vlad wakes up to find
his father who seems to have stayed up
all night tallying the bills Barnabas
then drops him off at school for his
inaugural day he then heads to the town
hall to settle some of his unfinished
work promising to return back soon as
soon as Vlad enters the school premises
he comes across a group of bullies
torturing another newcomer named wolf
thankfully there's another group of
girls led by Fay who saved the two of
them from the bullies soon after wolf
befriends Vlad and introduces him to his
parents who sniff him since they are
full-blown
werewolves he smells like peanut butter
on the other hand Barnabas arrives at
the Town Hall and files a complaint
against the list of bills that he
received the previous night fra an
employee informs him that the tax is
mandatory for all new residents Barnabas
expresses that he is unable to afford
such a huge amount and requests her to
break it into installments suddenly
their conversation is interrupted by the
town's mayor who asks Barnabas to The
ancestral blood fragment worn by Vlad in
order to settle their dues Barnabas
isn't sure about this as it belongs to
his son so he requests some time to
think back at school Vlad is waiting for
his father to return when he's
approached by a janitor hannapel who
suggests that he not miss the opening
speech following this the boy enters the
main hall where the school head mistress
is delivering Her speech to new students
and their parents the had mistress calls
all the new students onto the stage and
makes them stand in a line shortly after
Barnabas arrives and joins the other
parents in the audience the head
mistress then waves a magical spell from
her book which transforms all the new
students into their true forms wolf
turns into an actual werewolf like his
father Fay into a fairy and Vlad into a
young vampire and the bullies turn into
little dildos but soon after the Spells
effect Fades away and as a result fa
falls on Vlad causing him to sustain a
minor injury Vlad throws up when he
Witnesses blood dripping from his wound
simultaneously wolf begins to cough and
sneeze as if he has suffered from an
allergy after school the kids return
home embarrassed by the earlier
incidents it turns out that wolf is
allergic to fur even though he's a
werewolf a fact that enrages his father
similarly Vlad despite being a vampire
is sensitive to blood and Fay is afraid
of flying following this we see a
montage of all three magic kids on their
beds dealing with their own battles as
they've become the subject of ridicule
at school that night fra who turns out
to be a witch arrives outside vlad's
house with an intention of stealing the
blood fragment Crystal she uses her
superpower to extend her hand reaches
out into vlad's bedroom and steals the
fragment she then returns back to the
town hall and hands the crystal to the
mayor but to their surprise the fragment
mysteriously disappears from the mayor's
hand and appears back in vlad's room
this makes him realize that the blood
fragment is protected by a recall spell
and that it can be obtained only when
its owner hands it over with his free
will the next day when Vlad arrives at
school he sees the students watching a
video of Faith Falling onto him ah buot
tube as he heads to the classroom he is
intervened by a group of bullies they
pretend to be covered in fake blood
causing him to throw up hannapel notices
this and immediately fends off the
bullies berating them for their cruel
behavior however Vlad has already had
enough and he decides to leave the town
once and for all as he makes his way
through the forest he meets Fay and wolf
who are also trying to run away from the
town the trio then continues their
journey together after a while of
walking they come across the stone
bridge where they are stopped by
Quasimoto he prevents them from going
further he asserts that they can't leave
the town until they fulfill the prophecy
of cr's Feldon when the kids insist
Quasimoto turns into a giant troll in an
attempt to intimidate them but before he
can inflict any harm to the children
hanael shows up and rescues them after
this he takes them to his place and
offers the them some hot chocolate
during their conversation hanelle
discloses his true identity as a wizard
while he goes to prepare some food the
kids grab a book from his closet from
which they learn about the book of all
knowledge turns out that this special
book contains all the instructions on
fulfilling the prophecy the kids realize
that they can make their way out of the
town if they manage to retrieve the book
of all knowledge and fulfill the
prophecy but the only problem is that
the book is hidden in a forbidden
Library just in case you didn't already
think this was a Harry Potter ripoff
armed with this knowledge the three of
them head towards the Forbidden library
on their way they talk to each other
sharing about themselves and their
superpowers at this point in time we
learn that Fay possesses a healing power
which becomes evident when she heals a
dead plant if she'd healed vlad's wound
earlier she could have saved them all a
lot of misery not long after the trio
arrives at the Forbidden library and
manages to enter secretly inside they
discover a map that can lead them to
their desired book however ever the
place is guarded by a black dog with red
eyes I'm surprised it didn't have three
heads wolf manages to distract the dog
by offering his food allowing Vlad and
Fay to proceed further the two soon come
across a deep Abyss that must be
traversed to reach the library at this
moment Vlad uses his vampire sonar
powers to locate the invisible pillars
in the hole this enables them to LEAP
across and reach the other side
elsewhere fra visits Barnabas and uses
her love spell on him making him comply
with her instructions she then directs
him to persuade his son to sell the
blood fragment however Barnabas informs
her that Vlad ran away from school and
has not returned home yet back at the
library Vlad and Fay noticed that the
book they're looking for is placed in a
much higher compartment the only
solution is that faay must use her wings
to reach it despite her fear of heights
she nervously takes off and successfully
retrieves the book after this the three
rush to the exit narrowly escaping the
Vigilant black dog then they sit by a
tree and proceed to read the book it
tells them a story of the evil Lord
Lucifer whose goal is to turn all the
vampires werewolves and other monsters
into evil and gain control over humans
once more however they are unable to
learn more as the page has been torn out
from the book sensing that something bad
is about to happen the kids decide to be
brave oh never mind they decide to alert
their parents on the other hand the
mayor tracks Vlad down with the help of
fr's magical mirror and learns about his
access to the book of all knowledge
Furious he orders fra to do everything
she needs and bring the blood fragment
to him following this she retains the
reverse curse from her potion shelf and
sends it after the three children the
spell quickly Finds Its way inside their
bodies which makes them speak exactly
the opposite of what they're actually
trying to say as soon as Vlad arrives
home his possessed father tries to
persuade him to sell the blood fragment
despite the boy's attempts to resist the
spell renders him incapable of doing
doing so as a result he hastily rushes
to his room and locks himself inside
later on the three friends chat in a
group call and Fa says that they've been
cursed by the reverse spell now that
they're unable to seek help from their
parents the trio vows to resolve the
matter on their own later that night
Vlad delves into the book of all
knowledge to gather as much information
as possible but he eventually dozes off
the following morning when the group
reunites each of them reveals some
valuable information that they have
gathered putting everything together
together they discover that the blood
fragment has the power to reverse time
turning magical beings back to evil once
again to investigate further they head
to the town hall however they must
navigate past the police officer's cabin
to gain entry they then devise a
strategy wolf and Fay distract the
officer while Vlad infiltrates inside
vlad's crystal is drawn towards the
tower guiding his way up upon reaching
there he Witnesses a giant array of
crystals and the blood fragment turns
out to be its missing Peak as his
Crystal comes closer to the giant one
the time starts reversing changing his
backpack into the older version before
anything can happen further like his
Hotmail account reverting to blood for
me 69 Vlad grabs his fragment and runs
away simultaneously the mayor and froud
detect the child's presence and rush to
investigate the tower but find nobody
the mayor then discloses that he has
been amassing Crystal fragments for a
thousand years needing only the final
piece now here it's revealed that the
evil Lord Lucifer is none other than the
mayor himself since the time reversed
back to a moment earlier the book of all
knowledge also reverts to its original
state restoring the torn Pages as a
result the three children continue
reading about the prophecy they not only
uncover the mayor's true identity but
also discern his Sinister plan on the
solar eclipse day which happens to be
today he intends to cast the dark
crystals light upon the town's people
making everyone his slave slaves upon
learning this Vlad realizes that the
only way to save this town is by taking
the crystal away from the mayor so he
decides to leave forever wolf and Fay
want to accompany him but he refuses
emphasizing that they must stay to
protect the town with what skills you
might ask I have no idea in the next
scene the trio heads towards the stone
bridge and after bidding a final goodbye
to his friends Vlad proceeds to cross it
this time Quasimoto also permits his
departure but in an unexpected twist the
evil mayor shows up and holds Fay
hostage he blackmails Vlad to bring the
blood fragment to the tower within an
hour or else he'll kill his friend left
with no choice even though fa's life is
clearly not worth the end of the world
Vlad and wolf make their way to the
tower to save Fay once there Vlad
surrenders the blood fragment to Lucifer
releasing Fay from his custody as the
atmosphere turns dark due to the solar
eclipse the mayor fits the piece into
the Giant Crystal emitting a red light
but before the crystal can awaken the
blood fragment vanishes returning back
to hanael at this moment Vlad discloses
that he had entrusted the fragment to
Hannah pal before coming to the tower
this fills the mayor with rage and he
attacks the trio one by one he knocks
out Vlad and then throws Fay off the
tower seeing this wolf gets so Furious
that he transforms into a giant werewolf
and beats up the evil M however his
strength rength doesn't last long as his
allergies soon kick in and he reverts
back to his human form but before the
May can launches attack Fay returns and
uses her power to heal Vlad following
this Vlad turns himself into a vampire
and walks forward to confront the mayor
the boy uses his speed to trick Lucifer
into shooting the array of Dark Crystal
which rebounds at him this causes the
mayor to transform into a crystal that
bursts immediately amazing with the
threat finally neutr ized the three
young Heroes walk out of the Town Hall
hannapel approaches them and Returns the
blood fragment to Vlad the movie ends as
the three best friends walk away
discussing a name for their group
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching